為什麼台灣現在在全球股市上面的表現
相當的強就是我們整體的半導體供應鏈
真的很厲害啦
這個大概已經說破嘴
也很難形容 但是沒有關係
我們今天有隊長
9月就有一個半導體展示
非常盛大的展覽
那最近我們都知道先進封裝
真的叫全面爆單
還說 Intel要加進來一起幫忙
這怎麼回事
那這邊的話呢
除了三檔小台機
這個小台機裡面
還包含了可能橫跨到兩邊的單
都能吃
是的
那我想最近大家其實在反彈上來之後
看法其實我們剛剛這個
休息在聊天
有打腳派的嘛
也有盤整派
也有不打腳派的
也有直接公高派的啦
那我想直接公高
其實有可能就是要看半導體
因為有一些這個長多的
他其實還沒恢復元氣
籌碼比較亂
所以接下來這段時間呢
因為你太久沒有來對
鋰域你是不是
沒有 製作單位說要金句啦
是
對 但是金句他就順便放了這個
林志穎的照片出去
還有看一下
他說創新高是最強
這是我自己的金句
那長最多就是主流
因為其實接下來是
這一段時間大家找不到主流
例如說這個備弄元件
有一些可能從1000多塊
那疊回500-600
長到700
其實距離新高還有一段
那有一些其實創高
例如說南亞科有創高
可是有些模組廠其實沒有
他們比較稱之不起
那比較整齊的可能就是
這個ABF
那剩下就是半導體
所以我覺得大家其實
如果你是打腳派
或是盤整派
那倒不如選股不選市
那就找最安心的半導體
所以半導體還是我們最大的一個靠山
那不論是在這個9月1號 2號
這個Semi-come
這個聚焦山的主軸
先跟大家講
第一個
如果半導體蓬勃發展
貪污會不會很大
對
OK 那爆發式的規模整長
那台灣又是這個所謂的
多重產業的堆疊
讓整個AI重新定價台股
那這個時候講話就要大聲必須要說
我們的GDP
這個第一季15%
歪第二季12%
全年這個主計出估嘛
11%是全世界第一名
你要大聲講出來啊
大聲啊
這改定了
所以原則上呢
多從產業的堆疊
造成所謂的重新定價台股
這個台股世界最強
很合理啊
因為股市經濟的儲窗嘛
好 那三個重點
我們今天只抓一個啦
就是說這個先進制裁
我覺得會是重點
那當然 AI 基礎設施
因為其實我其實說不懂
因為你從三年前大家就在講
OEM 廣達 維穎 微創 紅海 人塑
這個合塑 神達什麼的
全部能組裝的
那說這些
不要說老什麼
就是老的新的
這個大家也都知道了
我覺得會重點或是在這個
那記憶體剛剛這個有這個
先進已經有講過了嘛
所以我覺得這個也當然也是重點
所以兩個都重點
那我們今天只挑一個就是說
我覺得先進製程的一個狀況
其實不只只有CoreWars、CoreWars
還有第二個叫做這個SOIC
這個系統整合的單晶片
甚至再把CPU整合進來
因為台積電的藍圖是做Cube
是說我稍微科普一下
GPU旁邊排8個HBF
這個叫做2.5D CoreWars
那本身自己GPU或ACC邏輯的堆疊
這個叫SOIC
那在整個晶片上面再放CPU進來
或是整個大完整的拼圖
這個東西都還在走
還在做大爆發
所以大家不要擔心
但把半導體的一個狀況
那資本資助增加
我想大家也就知道
那從CoAX裡面
還有一個FANOUT的PENAL LEVEL
就是說原本是用圓形的
細菌圓或者是CAREY
那換成PENAL
那換成面板呢
其實大家很簡單
我簡單畫一個圓就知道
那你切割成精力
不管你怎麼切
你邊邊的都不能用
這個是這個所謂邊角料
可是如果你是正方形
過長方形
你的產能利用率
經歷的狀況就增加很多
OK
那整個半導體的黃金年代
這個訓練道推理
還有這個卡哥瑞
這個43804億的
整個半導體的一個產值
這25%的
不要說黃金年代
真的就30年沒有見過了
是30年沒有見過的
那我們當然來看
哪一些股票是受惠的
那當然先從台積電來看
那資本支出增加
美國繳出漂亮的成績單
然後這個毛利率很高
這個部分我想
大家也都對台積電不陌生
那另外我等一下會補充就是說
英特爾之前股價是20幾
那從20幾以來呢
其實在美國政府入主
還有揮打入主之後
英特爾漲到100多
那整個所有Pending的案子都重啟
所以剛剛趙華講得很明白
就是說以前英特爾是股價
去年是25年新低
然後季辛格又走
我是福不奇的阿豆
現在英特爾是這個全世界
都覺得他是好棒棒的一個
而且美國政府的support太猛了
而且美國的這個半導體的領頭洋
我們台灣其實很多雙胯的
最後會講到
好
那萬一效果了這些設備股
其實我們就稍微點名幾個
其實跟COEUS相關的
就是軍華智盛的集團
OK 這個是
那萬一跟COEUS有關
那這個智盛還有這個加單
那我們稍微來看一下
其實最近表現
其實也都算是還不錯
先看萬潤
創新高就最強
漲最多就是主流
是
疊比人家少
例如說有些什麼聖誕樹的
駐公園
我們有講誰
聖誕樹是有
我們有介紹過幾個聖誕樹
我們是忠實觀眾
對不對
好 被割韭菜割泡菜之後
1400疊到700就是腰斬
或腳踝斬膝蓋斬
對
這個沒有
因為他之前在骨災之前
在這邊橫盤整理
我們講骨災
7月多 它頂多就1000多跌到800多
跌不到兩場是跟台積電一樣強的
它先跌了啦
對 先跌了
好 那也沒關係
說實話這個現行就不是聖誕樹
我們用這個
那再來它漲破這個所謂的
6月 7月的歷史高
沒錯
也許沒有過程前高
可是說實話相比於很多
一些比較元氣恢復比較慢的
不要再亂點名了
很多公司都是好公司
只是稍微估值高了
籌碼當然就比較亂
我們來看
業績真的有底氣
今年以來
營收累積成長42
7月跟6月的營收都是新高附近
大跳增
10億
大跳增的原因就在於
它有CPO的設備出道嘉義
我不能說嘉義是誰
我也不能說龍頭廠是誰
但光偶而設備是
法人最近看它
一個最新的亮點
所以除了coars原本以外
我覺得舊加薪是更好的
那萬論做什麼呢
其實萬論很簡單
做這個邦頂點焦跟貼
這一張我一直研究
是說貼合工藝機使
沒錯
好像在做裝潢
要做裝潢
那我簡單說
你晶片其實是很微小耐米的
那貼的上面要有焦
所以如果你焦太多
貼進去會溢焦
那出來旁邊都是晶片
那就完蛋了
因為那個影響很大
每一顆晶片其實都很貴
貼太少了
掉了
對 黏不住
不錯 很厲害
所以很簡單
如果從方到圓貼得要更多
材料不一樣
它的技術
它有一個很特殊的技術
所謂的連續的樂障冷縮的
圍圖塊的技術
敏感度等等
這個是它原本就滿厲害
這是COAX
當然因為COAX報單
這個造法已經開門見山了
所以他整個產能其實
台積電的Copos跟Copos是
Unscange一直在加
7萬片 10萬片 13萬片 18萬片
那除了這個再加了Copos
大概是三個題材
那第三個當然就是CPO
那Copos其實就是說
裡面積變大
那簡單說貼的就要變多
那原本是同樣的細的
那現在做了玻璃
這個比較難
這個叫Close Loop
叫做動態必迴路維力控
好啦就是利益器很難控制啦
利益器要輕輕點
維力控
對利益器的控制就是說
你不能太大力又不能太小力
對是這樣沒錯
簡單說是這樣
但是這個其實他們有announce
就是說因為其實這不是我們想的
那麼簡單
沒錯
所以大概是這樣子
那當然這個是萬論
那當然CPU就是說
台積電把光子整進去了做
Code Package
那他已經因為船
我們只能說都市船說
船六月七月
台積電已經在某一些
應該是說台灣的龍頭廠
在某一些這個CPO裡面
他在加大力度
那出他設備
明年展望聽說
一個光影型要8個CPO
這個模組
那他的設備其實貢獻
其實就蠻多的
這是光偶盒
這是萬論的這個市場的題材
那軍華的部分
其實軍華今年獲利是四五塊
那因為第二季財報比較差一點
所以前一陣子也是先疊
他疊的就蠻深的
這高疊做差有點深
這個就不屬於創新料最強
長最多就是主流
所以我兩頁就帶過他
沒有
但是
兩頁也不少
他也是頭肩底打得不錯
是
真的
隊長頭肩底
認真剛剛現同講要認真聽
左肩右肩
這也是準備整理
但我必須說
他真的是有三角收斂
他不是因為去槓桿
因為他本來是孤子太高
他不是那種聖誕樹
你自己去他那營收
5塊4塊
他今年法人孤30 明年50
其實獲利很好
對 獲利不錯
可是60倍本益比
我自己不會再60倍本益比獎
我們再20倍本益比獎
然後又有法人認為
第一個COAS受惠
那這個Apple 突了這個 WMCM 的這個封裝
那其實萬變不如其中
不管在哪裡做先進封裝
其實你最好的選擇只有台積電
那當然說 Intel 也有做 Immab
但是那個產能還是接台積電合勝的
我們沒有翻譯成英文的節目
所以就是他們都接台積電
吃肉喝湯剩下滴出來的
但原則上 Intel 也是可敬的對手
技術是還OK
我們這都會幫您特別翻譯
好 謝謝趕快彭博社來採訪我們
我講的就是產業的現況
你說整個Covas先進封裝
是讓整個台積電
再次超越對手的一個厲害的武器
那君華其實在這個呆邦的
其實也是跟這個貼合機
年經機有點相關
這個部分前中後段都會用到
那因為已經先疊
那其實整個這個
剛剛講的SOIC
就是這個概念就是這樣
它是原本的ASIC晶片在堆疊
所以除了HBN可以堆疊
那邏輯晶片也可以堆疊
所以今年其實蠻多設備
大家已經不講COWAS
因為這個是舊屏
用SOIC跟CPU
但這的確都是台積電在發展的事情
大概是這個樣子
所以聽起來它也蠻棒的
因為它也回到合理估值
對 但是我必須說
以它的現行跟它這個財報
還是有一點小弱
你說萬論營收在爆
然後有CPU
那君華有CPU
大家好像也不太知道
那君華有那個
我說SOIC
大家一直覺得他就是COAS
然後一直覺得他已經被炒作過了
所以他有一些先天上的優
你不能說他不好
因為他漲到1800多過
那其實這個東西就是
大家要從整個從網面分技術線
綜合來看
最後這個3分鐘壓箱寶
壓箱寶
這個前一陣子CB發行
轉換價在476
一直沒跌破
是
對 終於被我等到了
被你等到一個股災
股災
那這個股災快速站回來
所以原則上我認為
它就是一個橫盤整理
是
那整理在CB
因為它5月發
那3個月才可以轉換
所以壓3個月
因為創高
發CB拉高定價
對
整理3個月
這是我的祕密武器
好 因為現在剛好
就在CV這個價格
是的 所以回到這478
整個8月20幾號開始可以轉化
OK 那當然您買在這個定價下面
算是安全
再來營收創歷史新高
7月營收充起來了
是的 然後呢
獲利創歷史新高
那加登了
我們簡單來看一下
再回來這個營收
它其實是全球經援載具的
這個EVU PAD
EVU PAD的市占率的濃透
只有他跟intel
所以是寡戰
可是intel以前
這個跌到25年新低
所以現在他第二支腳好了
所以intel所有的案子都重啟
加等等於是復活了
那第二個他做這個所謂光照傳送盒
這個光照傳送盒
就有記憶體跟成熟製程
那他去年有一些大陸的一個
因為去年成熟製程比較差
所以他三支腳
除了先進製程的EUV
然後intel回來了
然後成熟智能跟記憶體也回來
那又是寡戰
營收或利用創立值新高
我覺得目前
除了股信比較差以外
我看不到他有任何產業上
還有基本面上的雜音
所以這個是EUVPOD
那金圓載具這個FOOP
是做成熟製程
裝金圓的
金圓是一片一片裝在這裡
所以例如說像海利市
他要來台積電做3D堆疊
下面的Best Die
他就用這個裝
他的HBN裝過來
台積電幫他做完
甚至連美國亞利桑那
也是這個裝過來
因為美國還沒有先進製程
所以這個東西
其實都跟家燈有關係
那最後我們回到這一頁
其實家燈的一個現行
在這邊回到這個468
然後營收獲利創新高
又加上整個產業寡占
我覺得它是一個很棒的未來
這個業績很好的一個公司
所以9月的展你會親自過去看
當然
其實在南港而已
所以登記一下就可以去了
歡迎大家一起來
也會比較著重在先進製程
先進風裝的這一塊做觀察
這邊非常謝謝隊長
隊長講產業真的非常生動
剛剛講說年要剛剛好
真的你想想看
你的手機換保護貼
你自己年都一堆氣泡
更何況是年金元
這麼樣精密跟高價的東西
所以相關的技術
在所謂的先進風裝裡面
真的是很重要
而股價當然率先已經上來
而且七月營收開始暴衝的
這是隊長覺得最重視的
剛剛陸續介紹了幾家公司
他壓香寶就是可以雙吃的囉
Intel就算要加入不加入
他都有Intel的訂單
而且有寡戰高的市佔率
這件事情是很重要的
不管台股要打幾隻腳
至少三隻腳都在的時候
未來的營運發展就值得期待喔
好今天非常謝謝三位的朋友
來到現場
雖然今天交頭比較冷清
但是來賓討論得很樂歷喔
因為台股的產業真的非常的多樣性
也具急劇發展性
那也希望今天的理財達人秀
對你透過幫助
明天再會了 拜拜